[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
development community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
VIC: Hello everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Vic.
I work on the Google
Drive SDK team.
Today I'm going to be going
through how to work with Go
and the Google Drive SDK.
So what we're going to do is
walk through our Quickstart
tutorial on writing a command
line application in Google's
Go language so that we can
upload a file to Google Drive
by running a simple command.
So here I have up the Google
Drive SDK documentation,
specifically our Quickstart
section.
And it enumerates all of the
steps that you need to do in
order to get running.
This tutorial usually takes
about five minutes or less.
I'll see how fast I
can do it today.
But it pretty much involves
four steps.
You're going to create an API
console project in the Google
API's console, enabling the
Drive API for that project.
You're going to install the
Google Go Client Library.
You're going to set up the Go
sample, and then you're going
to run the Go sample.
So if we come down here, the
first step is to create an API
project in the APIs console,
which is linked here.
I have it open.
So you can come up here and
create a new project.
And I will call this Google
Developers Live.
And if I create a project--
it just takes a second here.
And here we go.
So the first thing I have to
do in the project is enable
the Drive API.
So let me just flip that on.
And that's it.
So now that I've enabled the
drive API, I have to also set
up API access.
So what we're going to do here
is set up our OAuth 2.0
credentials and allow the
command line application to
actually access Google
Drive after the user
authorizes a request.
So I'm going to click this big
blue button here to create an
OAuth 2 client ID--
and Google Developers Live.
I don't have a product logo.
Click Next.
Now this is super important.
When you get to the client ID
settings, you have to select
the application type of
installed application, and not
web application.
Web application is a little
bit different.
It's meant for our other
flagship sample, which is the
DrEdit web application sample.
But we're not writing web
applications today.
We're writing a command
line application.
So that's an installed app.
And then it's not an
Android or iOS app,
so we just use Other.
And then Create client ID.
And then that's it.
So right here, I have the
client ID for installed
applications.
And here, you can see my
client ID and secret.
So these are going
to be important
in just a few minutes.
Once we've got that done,
we're done in
the Google APIs console.
Come back to the
documentation.
And the next step is
to install the
Google Go Client Library.
I've already run these commands
on my workstation
here, but I'm just going
to run them again.
Nothing's going to happen.
So you can see, I've already got
the Google Go API Client
Library installed.
So with that done, the next
thing I'm going to do is
actually add the source code.
So I've got this source
code copied and
pasted here into main.go.
If I take a look at this,
you can see just a
bunch of source code.
There are two things that we
have to change in this file.
If you download or copy and
paste the tutorial code,
you'll see these two strings
here, your client ID and your
client secret.
These are the only two things
that you have to change in the
source code to get it to work
for your application.
And what you do is come here to
the Google APIs console and
copy your installed application
client ID and
client secret.
And then you paste to those
into the source code where
appropriate, here.
And that's it.
So everything else you
can leave alone.
I'm going to leave the rest of
source code alone for now.
And then we'll come back and
look at that in a minute.
The other thing we're going to
need to do before we can run
the sample is actually create
a file to upload.
So here I've got document.txt.
And it says "hello world,"
so that's good enough.
And that's the file I'm
going to upload.
So with that, the last thing
to do is actually run the
sample, which we document
right here.
It's a simple command,
go run main.go.
So if I run this, the first
thing the application is going
to do is ask me to browse
to this URL.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about what that means.
Essentially, we need to the
application to have
an OAuth 2.0 token.
And it doesn't have one
on the initial run.
So because it doesn't have one
on the initial run, it asks us
as the user to browse to this
URL in a web browser and then
click Allow Access.
What this is going to do
is grant a token to our
application via this
authorization code.
So we're going to copy this
authorization code back into
the application, which is
secure, waiting for our input.
And with that, the application
is going to upload
document.txt up into
Google Drive.
There it is.
We can see here that
it was created with
this ID and this title.
So if that's the title--
let me go into Google
Drive here.
And right now you see
nothing here.
Let me refresh.
And here's our document.
If I open this up, you can see
here that there's no preview
available, but this is
our test document
that was just created.
So that's pretty much it for
how the sample works.
Now let's take a look through
the source code and see just
what's going on.
So if I come back here to the
tutorial source code, the
first part of the source code,
primarily, is a set of
imports, and then
a configuration.
The configuration is somewhat
important because that's where
you set your client
ID and secret.
Everything else here is not
super critical for getting
started with this command
line application.
And then here what we're doing
is generating the URL to visit
for authorization, which
is this step here.
It's generating the URL that the
user browses to to grant
an authorization code
and get a token for
the subsequent requests.
So once we do that, we generate
that and print it.
So go to the following link to
your browser, and then there's
the authURL.
Once you print it, the user
browses to it, and then we
receive some input
from the user.
So we scan that line.
And the rest of this is just
error checking, if the code
doesn't exchange, for
a granted token, or
anything like that.
So now we create a new
authorized Drive client.
This is very straightforward.
If there's an error,
we show the error.
And then we create
a new Drive file.
And we're going to set its title
to "My Document," as we
saw before, and its description
to "My test
document." With that
done, we open
document.txt with a file pointer.
And then all we do is
insert the file
using the Drive service.
And once that's done, we get a
JSON representation of that
new file back, and all of its
metadata, including things
like ID and title
and description.
And here, we just want to
print its ID and title.
So you can see that that's
exactly what was printed out
here at the end of the
program execution.
So that's the Go Quickstart
sample.
Now once you've gotten to this
point, there are some next
steps you could take.
So we have full support for
obviously a number of other
features in Google Drive that
you can access via the SDK.
So once you've gotten the hang
of this, I recommend you maybe
extend this application
to do something
like download a file.
Which is a little
bit different.
When you download a file, you
have to do more than just this
one line of code.
You have to let the
user know--
let the user provide you
which file to download.
And then you have to go and you
have to fetch it, getting
its download URL, and then
downloading the actual
contents of file locally.
So that's a little
bit different.
You could also clean up the
authorization mechanism.
So right now, as a user of this
application, I have to
come in here and copy this URL,
paste it into the web
browser, and then in a web
browser, I have to click Allow
Access and copy the
authorization code back into
the application.
That's pretty tedious
for a user.
So instead what we could do is
a fire up the web browser on
behalf of the user.
So for instance, we could open
Google Chrome directly to the
authorization page.
And then we could start a local
web server on the user's
computer in order to have the
authorization page at Google
redirect back to the user's
local computer.
And with the web browser
running, we could actually
receive the authorization code
straight from Google.
So this means that the user
wouldn't have to paste this
authorization code into the
application, but our web
browser that we have running
locally would be
able to pick it up.
So that's something that a lot
of people do with an installed
application.
It's not that hard to do.
You just have to start of the
web browser for the user,
which there's plenty of
frameworks to do.
On Linux, you could for instance
use xdgopen, and then
you have to start the
local web browser--
again, there's tons of ways
to do this, and it's very
straightforward--
and receive the incoming
request, and parse out the
authorization code.
And then you just continue
as normal.
So essentially, when the user
ran this application, they
would never see these lines.
They would only see their web
browser pop up with the
authorization page.
And when they clicked Allow
Access, you could here in your
application just continue
on uploading the file.
So that's pretty much everything
for the Go
Quickstart.
If you have any questions,
please
find us on Stack Overflow.
Our tag is Google-Drive-SDK.
We're happy to answer anything
that you come up with.
And if you want to take the next
steps into something a
little bit more advanced, then
definitely check out our
DrEdit sample applications.
Our DrEdit sample applications
will allow you to write a web
app that integrates with Google
Drive and exposes your
application in the Google Drive
user interface, allowing
users to access different parts
of your application to
Create New and Open With on
a document right there.
So that's pretty much it.
Thanks very much, and thank
you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]